cover yourself ice again
cover your eyes mother father
[Music]
okay open your eyes
[Music]
will you marry me
yes
i feel
happy and surprised
this moment i'll never forget it
because i know
that there is love in our hearts
this moment is everything and the fact
that my daughters are right here
by her side
means so much to me wow
a year ago i don't think we were truly
ready
to be engaged and now
it feels right and
i believe in us
yes
oh it's perfect yeah it does
he's beautiful baby
really pretty yeah
i've never seen anybody be proposed to
in person and my first time is like with
my mom and it just makes it so much more
special exactly like it's such a
romantic moment with like the sunset
on the beach and like the flowers and
the ambiance i'm so happy for my mom my
mom looks super happy as well like it's
just something that you'll never forget
[Music]
girls i want to say really
help you here and are going to want me
to be your stepdad yes
i love your mom and i love you guys
in the last proposal in rhode island we
weren't a part of it but now the fact
that georgie included us in the special
moment really makes me think a lot
different about him
spending all this time with him i
do believe he has good intentions to
prove to us that he really is in it for
love
[Music]
you